hi guys I'm Eric Voss and a new trailer
for Wonder Woman is here and I feel like
they cannot make a bad trailer for this
movie everything about it looks great we
get more of a sense of the story of this
movie along with some possible villains
there's also a ton of Easter eggs here
and I'm gonna break down all the stuff
that you missed also be sure to watch
our other breakdown of the first Wonder
Woman trailer from Comic Con last summer
we got into a lot more about one woman's
origin in the comics and what version of
her that we'll see in this movie also
fun fact that video was like one of the
first youtube videos I ever hosted so go
on take a trip through memory lane like
four months ago look at that shy little
sugar cookie anyway let's get started
I used to want to save the world
so in our opening shots we see Wonder
Woman Diana Prince walking in front of
the Louvre museum in Paris and we can
see those famous glass pyramids those
were completed in 1989 which confirms
that part of this movie will be set in
the present day I'm thinking that this
scene could be part of like a prologue
framing device and the rest of the film
is a flashback to Diana's origin story
and world war 1 kind of like the framing
device of the movies Sigmund Private
Ryan now it was implied that Batman vs
Superman that Diana was an antiquities
dealer remember she was looking at that
sword in the museum scene so it could be
that she actually works in the Louvre in
their archive section then we see Diana
looking at this old photograph which is
the same one that we saw in Batman vs
Superman remember that's how Bruce Wayne
out in Diana in the most dramatic way
email attachment now this photo is old
enough that it looks like it could be
the original and if you look super close
to this shot the note in the background
is written on stationery with the Wayne
logo and I'm sorry but no matter how
much zooming and enhancing I did I
couldn't make out what this note said
sorry guys my vision just isn't that
good but regardless judging from the
context it seems like Bruce Wayne got
his hands on the original photo and sent
it to Diana as a way to say to her look
you have the original no more copies are
going out your secret is safe with me
and this photo ends up in with triggers
Diana's memory into the past also it's
interesting what Diana says here I used
to want to save the
now from a storytelling standpoint this
whole thing is great the Diana we saw in
Batman vs Superman was still pretty
reluctant to jump back into the action
she didn't want to interfere in human
drama she's old and weary though I gotta
say these Justice League heroes pull-off
grizzled very well so in order to
establish why Diana would really care
about joining the Justice League in this
upcoming war there's an emotional need
for Diana to revisit the time when she
still cared about saving the world from
destruction so this won't be just a DC
origin story for the heck of it way to
justify taking millions more of our
dollars DC moving on this beautiful
place
but the closer you get the more you see
the great darkness within so here we get
the first of this trailers gorgeous
shots of theme Sakura Paradise Island
that's the home of Diana and the rest of
the Amazonians now in the real world
this was shot on the beaches of
Cammarata in southern Italy and we
talked about this in the first trailer
breakdown but they've added these
cool-looking rock formations and posts
to give this location even more of a
mysterious look and explain why this
place is so secluded because it would be
really hard for ships to navigate around
those rocks and I just really love this
shot of Diana watching Steve Trevor's
plane crash into the water it reminds me
of that epic shot from the opener of
season 3 the TV show lost when the
others watched the plane break up over
the island and just like in that moment
this plane crash is a mix of that
excitement of worlds colliding but also
the sense of doom and conflict that that
kind of collision usually leads to again
Diana's voice over is really interesting
here this beautiful please as we see
this beautiful island and it seems like
she's kind of regretting saving Steve
here in the long run because it took her
out of this utopia into the dirty smoky
man's world and while her words work on
that level they also imply her worldview
that the events of this movie will leave
her with this beautiful world is
referring to the entire world planet
Earth and her decision to try to save it
through all the horrors of World War one
they showed her how dark humanity can be
and why it's sometimes hard to justify
fighting for them let's move on
and I learned this the hard way a long
long time ago
okay if you freeze this shot at just the
right frame you'll see that the bow that
all these soldiers are jumping out of
says schwaben that's the German form of
Swabia that's a region in verb area on
Germany's southern border so that
confirms our theory from the last video
that the footage we saw of Steve Trevor
posing as a German pilot and stealing a
German plane is probably an early action
scene with Steve getting into trouble or
discovering something at that base
narrowly escaping and getting chased and
shot down near that mascara in some lost
corner of the Adriatic Sea or the
Mediterranean and it seems like that
chase could be what led these German
soldiers to this island resulting in
this epic 300 style beach clash between
Germans and Amazonians with one of them
doing the sickest swing move I've ever
seen with a bow and arrow and I should
know because I've seen nothing like that
ever but by the looks of things here
it's a blind that she takes his German
bullet and possibly dies pretty early in
the film may just like graze her or
seriously wound her which would still
freak Diane out because she would have
seen this kind of weapon before and no
matter what this would be kind of a
wake-up call to convince Diana that she
needs to intervene in the affairs of man
to prevent them from continuing to use
this kind of lethal force on each other
and since the Germans are sending this
many soldiers after Steve whatever he
did or discovered must have been pretty
huge but I'll come back to that if you
look closely here there's a separate
group of five figures charging at the
Germans separate from the rest of the
Amazonian cavalry and if you look super
close to that figure on the far right it
kind of looks like different clothes
like the long German officer coats Steve
was wearing in the other parts of the
scene so my guess is that is Steve
Trevor with Diana being one of the other
four okay so putting all this together
with the other shots of this beach scene
it looks like this is Steve Diana and a
few other Amazonians maybe just shortly
after Steve washes up on the beach then
these Germans arrive and they're like
and OVAs despite and Diana's like um no
I've never seen a man before and I'm not
just gonna give them away and then the
Germans like okay fine and then they
charge at them and then the other
Amazonian swooped in to save the day or
maybe the scene is happening later like
after Steve is metal the Amazonians I'm
know we'll see all right moving on
your mission to stop the war what war
the war to end all wars weapons far
deadlier than you can ever imagine
welcome Bahamas okay I'll have to talk
about here first Steve Trevor explains
to Diana and Queen Hippolyta how he's
trying to prevent the war to end all
wars and in the early 20th century
people just referred to World War one as
the Great War no one called it World War
one the sequel wasn't approved yet part
of the reason for that thinking is that
this was the first war to use chemical
warfare on such a mass scale things like
mustard gas that had a devastating
effect on soldiers this is why you can
find all those creepy photos of people
wearing gas masks during World War one
like a lot of soldiers and civilians too
had to run drills to quickly throw it on
even though many of them were so crudely
made that they didn't really work it was
terrifying and so I love the way that
this movie appears to be working in that
history of chemical warfare now this
shot of Steve walking I think that's a
reverse angle the shot that we saw in
the last trailer and the building is
walking towards has these smokestacks
I'm thinking it could be a chemical
weapons plant run by the German military
so the thing that Steve discovered may
have to do with some new deadly gas
weapon that might not just win the war
for Germany but changed the course of
history and that deadly gas could be
based on this stuff that we see in the
globe like in real life
none of the gases that they use in World
War one were known to shatter the
eyepiece of a gas mask
except maybe Kaiser Wilhelm's farts mmm
that brings us to this character creepy
face mask lady who he said in the last
video looks like mr. hero from Boardwalk
Empire and again a lot of people during
those times actually wore masks like
this because their faces were so
disfigured by things like mustard gas
and other terribly violent injuries they
sustained during the war and we see the
same woman show up a few times in this
trailer and she throws what looks like
some kind of explosive into a room and a
lot of people are saying that this
character could be an interesting
villain from the Wonder Woman comics dr.
poison now in the comments dr. poison is
a woman named princess Marui and she
hides her face with a hood and she
conspires with the Nazis in World War
two and try to contaminate the Allies
water supply with Reverso which is a
chemical that makes soldiers do the
opposite of whatever orders are given
now I'm thinking that this movie could
be updating doctor poison into this
rogue chemical weapons expert who's got
her hands on this new deadly weapon and
she could be either in league with the
Germans and the rest of the Axis powers
or playing both sides it's like kind of
a dangerous radical but there's another
villain who shows up in the section this
guy played by Danny Huston he showed up
in the last trailer and then we made a
few guesses that this could be someone
like Kaiser Wilhelm but if you notice
this framed picture on the wall which
you see better in the shot with possible
doctor poison that's actually Kaiser
Wilhelm so this guy probably isn't him
but the other person that we said this
guy could be is Ares he's the God of War
Diana's half-brother in a major
recurring enemy to Wonder Woman in the
comics the theory is that Ares has taken
a human form in the shape of this German
officer and this trailer definitely
makes it seem like that theory as
possible so like notice how this guy
says welcome to ours it definitely makes
him sound a bit more ambitious than your
average German general so like in World
War one the Germans were really just
dragged into the conflict because of
their alliances and it was really just a
war of contrition for them
unlike in World War two when obviously
the Germans really did one world
domination and this ambition obviously
lines up with Ares who craves war and
power they're actually more clues later
on in this trailer that point in this
direction and before we move on I just
quickly want to pause on this shot of
this weird-looking explosion on top of a
guard tower now the trailers editing
makes it look like this is caused by the
thing that possible doctor Poisson
tosses but that was in a large bunker
typed room of a German base whereas this
looks like a small tower with like some
British soldiers below like those gas
masks are actually the same crude ones
worn by British soldiers in World War
one but like what is this explosion it's
way more advanced than really any kind
of firepower that anyone actually had in
World War one so my guess is that this
could be an explosion that causes the
gas masks a Turing toxin to spread I
could see this scene is like a tragic
moment that raises the stakes through
Steve and Diana to stop this weapon from
getting into the wrong hands any further
okay really not before you are in more
danger than you think
cannot stand by while innocent lives are
lost
be careful Diana
okay so here we see Diana suiting up
with her Amazonian shield and sword if
you look closely in the shot you can see
the rest of her one-woman garb in the
foreground with the red and blue and
gold colors and the Wonder Woman sigil
now in the last trailer we saw shot of
Hippolyta handing off her crown to Diana
and I feel like this could be a scene
we're like Diana's going against her
mother's wishes to join the world of man
sneaking out with all this gear but then
Hippolyta catching her in the act and
then ultimately giving her her last
minute blessing also I love the contrast
up establishing shots that open and
close this section so like first we get
the clear picturesque famous cura
Paradise Island followed by the smoky
polluted downtown London - they get into
I need one of those like gas masks just
to like walk around and by the way the
reason why there's so much smoke in
London here is that during the war all
of England transformed into this
industrial state with nearly every
building in London cooking up like
weapons parts supplies for the war
effort
except that one right there that plume
of smoke clearly came straight from
Kaiser Wilhelm's ass mmm
who's this woman she's my secretary sir
she's a very good secretary so here we
see Steve and Diana walk through this
office with a bunch of arguing British
officers so where do we think this is
now assuming Steve is a spy working with
British intelligence this might be the
opposite of mi6 which was actually
founded during this time period to spy
on the Germans and this is really a shot
in the dark here but that portrait might
be the services founder Mansfield Smith
coming who before founding mi6 was a
captain in the Royal Navy but I'm not
really sure that guy was super secretive
and there's really only one image I can
find up him and he didn't have a
moustache there so I could be wrong and
I'm loving this mildly upset stiff by
the door who's like shooting them as
Stern British flair and that kind of
suggests that this is a meeting with
like high security clearance and all
these guys are like quite put off to see
a woman Jordan in the proceedings now of
course a lot of the humor when a woman
is gonna be seeing the struggle of a
female demigod making the transition
from a female dominated society to a
male-dominated one with Diana clearly
being stronger than Steve and all these
guys but having to pretend to be a
subordinate to not draw attention and I
like this call back to the first trailer
with Steve calling Diana his secretary
who's this who's my secretary remember
the first trailer ended with that clay
dianna asking what a secretary is what
is the secretary I go where he tells me
to go and I do what he tells me to do
yeah Diana's clearly not want to be
labeled a secretary within this cool
shot of Diana heroically blocking a
bullet with a wrist armor and then Steve
catching a bullet like hot potato in it
like a little wimp it's just a great way
to show that disparity between their
actual toughness also narrative belief
speaking I'm not really sure why they're
being shot at in the first place but I'm
thinking it gives the movie more of this
like cloak-and-dagger spy games kind of
vibe like James Bond or Jason Bourne and
like these two could have assassins
trying to take them out at every turn
okay moving on this is our sacred duty
to defend the world and it's what I'm
going to do
okay so here we see Steve and Diana and
this guy who shows up later in the
trailer crossing a bridge as they passed
several wounded soldiers returning home
from the frontlines meaning that Steve
and Diana are headed towards the front
line based off Diana's reaction here it
seems like this movie isn't really gonna
shy away from the heavy emotional toll
that the First World War took on
soldiers many of whom were left with
severe PTSD and then as we see Diana
step out of the trenches into the
no-man's land that's the place that
separates the opposing lines that
literally no man can walk out into
without getting shot I'm actually
beginning to think that this might be
part of Diana's mission to cross enemy
lines since really she's the only one
with the actual power to do it because
why else would they send a valuable
intelligence officer and this female
demigod right to the spot where
frontline soldiers are just getting
killed it's probably not just so they
could get that awesome slow-mo shot of
one room and obliterating a bullet on
her wrist armor I'm pretty sure these
two have a reason to be here and judging
by Steve's shocked reaction I really
don't think the mission was for Diana
just marched right down the middle of
the area and broad daylight maybe they
were trying to find some other way
around but before we move on I just
gotta point this out this guy's eyes
like damn it's like he's not a ghost or
maybe he just really doesn't want Diana
to die like oh my god am I gonna be good
no okay moving on
okay so in this section we get some
great action along with some footage
that we saw in the first trailer but
there are just a couple things that I
want to point out okay so first off in
this German military ball scene we get a
new shot of Steve and what looks like a
German officer uniform so that confirms
the theory that he and Diana are
undercover disguises Germans to get into
this ball maybe so that Diana can attack
Dani Houston's character possibly Ares
we'll talk more about a second also we
see Steve flying his plane over this
massive explosion if you look closely at
the flames you can see the smokestacks
of that German chemical weapons factory
collapsing so it looks like part of the
reason all these Germans are chasing
Steve at the beginning the movie is he
bombed
also if you notice his plane definitely
gets caught the flames a little bit and
maybe that's what cripples his engine
and causes him to crash land at them
oscuro we also see Diana doing this
impressive backflip now in most of the
comics Wonder Woman actually can fly but
remember this is an origin story where
she's still kind of like coming into her
powers so I'm betting that we'll be
seeing a lot of cool jumps and maybe if
we're lucky a little wink at her
learning to fly but if you look at this
tall barbed-wire fence it looks like it
could be part of a prisoner of war camp
and you can see that same guard tower in
the background which makes me think that
that explosion we saw before could be
part of like a rescue attempt of a bunch
of POWs which maybe ends up going really
poorly and becomes kind of like a false
to feed for Diana that she has to
overcome and then this shot of possible
doctor poison is one of the most
menacing shots of the trailer that's a
look of pure anger and hate right there
I think we're really gonna like this
villain also you can see a piece of her
mask flapping in the wind a little
that's such a cool subtle detail now
check out this shot Wonder Woman is
using her lasso of truth against this
guy who kind of looks like Danny
Houston's character from earlier and if
so this is part of the reason I think
that he could be Ares
no like normal human could take this
kind of beating it could be where we end
up seeing these two deities siblings
Duke it out towards the end of the movie
and I suspect that Ares might end up
taking another more terrifying form for
their final battle which we wouldn't
have seen any part of yet alright moving
on
okay so let's sort through this chaos
was like rebel and explosions and focus
on a couple things here so this shot of
Danny Huston swinging Dianna sorted her
to me is the clearest evidence I can see
that this guy is Aries the two of them
really just do seem like equal matches
like this is this epic collision between
deities and sorry I just don't picture
this old stout German officer being able
to keep up with Wonder Woman
blow-for-blow
by the way that shot behind them is
driven for caution smoking prohibited
which makes me think that this location
is some kind of lab or munitions factory
with explosives maybe where he's
producing this new weapon on a mass
scale also this shot happens so fast you
might miss it but when Diana kicks off a
piece of rubble as it lifts up she
hovers over it for a second and it
almost looks like she's actually flying
there so it could be in like the heat of
the final battle diana makes this almost
accidental discovery and then uses it to
finish him off I don't know we'll see I
know everyone's been talking about it
but this electric guitar what a woman
theme is so great it honestly might be
my favorite music from any superhero
movie like in a while and it might just
be because I can't remember any music
from any superhero movie at all it kind
of blends together honestly but not this
so feel like I'm gonna be humming German
for like a long time and now let's move
on to this last little part of the
trailer okay the woman possibly fighting
this fight we use our principles
although I am NOT opposed to engaging in
a bitter fisticuffs should the occasion
arise so the lovable edit candy returns
in the closing seconds of this trailer
as well which makes me think that she's
just gonna pop up into the end of every
scene with like a joke or some kind of
like quirky gesture and honestly I
really do hope that this movie finds
more time for these like Etta Diana
scenes because it's pretty charming to
see these two become best friends and
considering the next time we'll see
Wonder Woman will be 100 years after
this these two really gotta live it up
while they can like I want to see the
two of them get drunk in a pub and like
wreck it in this bar fight or why don't
we just give them their own spin-off
Diana
you crushed all the furniture again
okay no uh let me know what you think
about this trailer in the comments again
be sure to check out our breakdown to
the comic-con trailer as well as our
breakdown at the Justice League trailer
now if you like this video please hit
like and subscribe to new rockstars for
more of these videos you can also
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our current patrons we love
you guys hit me up on Twitter at EA boss
with any dots that you might have on the
one-woman trailer you can also follow
new rock stars at new rock stars and
bother them about what our videos are
coming out anyway thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you